then one day I'm in my office in
Woodland
Hills yeah who's this yeah you you owe a
you know tax assessor were here your 85
whatever $885,000 said for what you're
in a district you have to pay you're
grown your business is grown this is how
much money you I said what are you
talking about I call my accountant who's
downstairs under you know our floor eth
floor I say hey what is this all about
he says well if they CAU you and they're
coming around they knock on doors that
are grown it's hit a Miss if they don't
come to you you don't have to pay it wow
but if they come to you and they know
you're a grown business they can tax you
you're in District I said are you
serious so we have to pay this check
then I said what districts don't they
have
this do you consider yourself political
cuz we're crossing paths now a lot and
and the type of people that are watching
us are very similar in in the political
sense of things but I can never tell if
you really are political like I saw you
at the GOP debate that's a pretty
political thing I go on your show we
talk about politics uh you wait you
didn't do the San thing yet right they
was it was scheduled but the hurric the
hurricane hit also cuz he was he was
going to you and then he was coming to
me that afternoon and then and then the
hurricane hit but but obviously you're
you're political and the things that you
talk about but do you consider yourself
a a political person what what does a
political person mean what how well that
you really like you like you really like
the game of politics you really like the
uh not like you you're passionate about
the issues like you really think about
all of the issues and I do my parents
got a divorce you know I watch these
guys get two divorces and remarry each
other twice right and she was what got
married married and divorced twice
married my sister's born they get a
divorce two years later they remarry I'm
born then they get a divorce again
that's my and that was it though they
didn't get back together after that they
can't if they're in the same room
they're going to resurrect on that one
movie people so but my mother's side a
lot of them were Communists and my dad's
side a lot of them were imperialist
these guys love the shot they hated the
Sha these guys you know loved capitalism
they hated capitalism they loved KL
marks that was their Bible Stalin he was
a great leader for Russia USSR all these
rich greedy people in America all they
care about is money we care about family
why would you work that hard you should
come home and come home at 3:00 and have
watermelon and cheese and cut it up and
sit down and have a conversation
together who cares about the car you
drive who cares about this this this
this that and I watched it so for me I I
didn't like politics cuz I saw the fact
that the two people I love the most got
a divorce because of politics but then
that that was really it it it was
brother oh my God I mean one of them
their philosophy was rich people are
greedy and all they care about is money
and the other one was poor people are
lazy like you just can't get over that
it's just like and that was just
ingrained and but at that time it wasn't
politics it was more like why did these
guys why' you guys get married in the
first place and thank God you did but
why'd you get married in the first place
what was the whole purpose behind it so
then I go to Germany and then we come to
the states and when I come to the states
I go to the Army and then I'm that was
the first time where military you know
stuff was going on President Bush and
Clinton and all this kind of stuff was
going on and I'm like interesting what's
going on here then I went into financial
services and started competing and then
I realized politics is involved in
insurance department of insurance
politics is involved in being a cop
being a firefighter running good
business regulation financial industry
SEC nastd it's involved everywhere
and then when we were small insurance
company politics doesn't do anything for
you or not you're small nobody cares who
you are you're tiny then when we got
bigger and then all of a sudden we have
a business that's National we're apped
in 49 states and we have offices all
over the country a few hundred offices
then you notice there's a lot of
politics involved all the guys that were
all nice to you and now they're like you
know oh you can build anything you want
you can be as big as you want and then
they're like oh he actually became
as big as they wanted now it's like you
took business away from us and you're
this and you're that I'm like oh so
there is politics M then you go and you
start studying had dinner with George
Will in 2009 March with the Claremont
Institute and I go to this event and I
watch what you know he's talking about
with Larry AR and Larry Greenfield and
all these guys and I'm going to these
events with the owner of public storage
at you know Malibu and I'm having these
meetings with John Voit and you know
Larry uh Dennis Prager coming then I
launch a show in 2009 with KK KLA called
saving America a year later I shut it
down because my San Francisco office
closed down they said I cannot believe
you started a show and you know how dare
you do this kind I'm like wait a minute
what's going on with politics then one
day I'm in my office in Woodland
Hills yeah who is this yeah you you owe
a you know tax assessor were here you ow
US 85 whatever $85,000 so for what
you're in a district you have to pay
you're grown your business is grown this
is how much money I said what are you
talking about I call my account who was
downstairs under you know our floor eth
floor I say hey what is this all about
he says well if they caught you and
they're coming around they knock on
doors that are grown it's hit a Miss if
they don't come to you don't have to pay
it wow but if they come to you and they
know you're a grown business they can
tax you you're in this District I said
are you serious so we have to pay this
check then I said what districts don't
they have this 13 of them Victorville
Santa Monica Burbank blah blah blah I
said okay I'm going to go to Burbank
lundo so we move our headquarters to
bbbank Glendo so I don't have to worry
about this and we're in Glendo at the
New York Life building and and all of a
sudden I'm like no we're not staying
here um Time Magazine comes out with the
article United States of Texas then we
go to Texas we have a meeting with
Governor Perry with mayor maso from
Frisco was the fastest grown city in
Texas then we go to a Rangers game with
Nolan Ryan and we watch how these guys
are recruiting businesses to Texas this
is when Rick Perry would go to
California he would do radio show if you
don't like the business they take and
care of you we going to take care of you
here in Texas and we like okay great so
then we moved to Texas we fell in love
with
Texas and then Co happens politics goes
to a whole different level my content
was always around business Mafia
interviews it was not a political thing
then all of a sudden politics becomes
relevant on what we're doing with Co and
then I said no so your politics were
your politics were probably you were
kind of right leaning in that you were
probably for small government right less
regulation less taxes blah blah BL then
coid hits and that's what basically
drove us both here I had a pretty
freaking good life in LA and then on
whatever that day wasch 1th or whatever
it weeks toop the spread day two I was
like this place is never coming back and
you know I I fought very hard I
campaigned with Larry Elder for the
recall and I don't know if I've told you
this you know that three days after the
recall you know what happened you talk
about getting a knock on your door from
the tax man I got audited by the state
of California after I publicly was
backing lariel during campaigning makes
sense I put my house for sale that day
that day like that tells you all you
need to know so isn't that a weird thing
about how your your life better match up
with your politics otherwise yeah you're
in a lot of trouble see I I have a
problem with that because for me and
what I mean by I have a problem with
that is I have a problem with bullies uh
I'm I'm a you know so here's what's
going on today you know believe it or
not the majority will forgive people
lying to them the government lying to
them they'll get over it they'll cry
about it but they'll get over it the
majority will even tolerate being taken
advantage of if you think about this
been going on in America I can't believe
you're doing it you're not going to do
nothing about it you're going to go back
to your state in California not leave
and California is going to you ain't
leaving anyways so stop you will tweet
about it angrily for you're not going to
do nothing there is no action it's just
yeah watch watch what I'm going to do
watch yeah I'm going to punch you in the
face go ahead
yeah and then you get back in your car
and you leave right that's most people
in California but here's the
problem you cross the line with kids
yeah you just woke up an animal because
a mother went through 40
weeks so mother is automat most vested
thing you're going to be in your life is
carrying a a human being for 40
weeks you haven't gone through the pain
you want to groom my kids I'm good man
we're not going to do this all of a
sudden what the hell happened to this
guy's you know rage I've never seen you
be like this what happened to all these
mothers what happened to all these
parents California UK you know Texas New
York what they're waking up so here's
the
part for most part most people there
there's a saying that says whatever you
don't hate you learn to tolerate most
people just don't like it mhm you know
but a few of us have a lower tolerance
level for you crossing the line if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop screaming check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell